When Al Vegetarian ancestors started
eating meat around 2 million years ago,
it wasn't just because animals
taste great. It was pure necessity.
Climate change made many of the plants
that our ancestors relied on less
available and meet bridge.
That gap from the discovery of fire at
the latest meet became a staple of the
human diet. But over the last few years,
eating meat has increasingly been
associated with health risks like heart
disease, certain cancers,
and an early death.
So how unhealthy is meat really?
In this video, we'll only talk about meat.
Dairy products deserve a video
of their own. Biologically,
we need to eat for three reasons,
for energy to acquire materials to
fabricate ourselves and to get special
molecules that our bodies
can't make themselves.
The energy and most of the materials come
from the three macro nutrients, fats,
carbohydrates, and proteins.
Proteins are the most important
resource for repairing and replenishing
ourselves. Structures.
The special molecules are a large variety
of vitamins and minerals we need to
drive metabolic processes. Meet
provides us with most of these things.
It contains all the essential
amino acids, our body needs,
and a lot of minerals like iron,
zinc and essential vitamins,
some of which are barely found in plants
like vitamin B 12 only one essential
nutrient is missing and most of
the meat we consume. Vitamin C is,
appears in almost all plants and
supports our immune system as what is the
development of connective tissues.
After a few months without hit,
you'd get scurvy, but meat
has another big advantage.
It's high bioavailability,
some of the nutrients in me to broken
down faster and available quicker than
those from plants. Spinach, for
example, contains more iron than meat,
but it's absorbed much slower and the
body needs more energy to digest it.
Several health benefits have also been
observed in communities that rely solely
on meat. The Nus, for example,
are able to survive in
extreme climate conditions,
thanks to eat purely meat based diet.
Since they consume the whole animal,
including the organs they get
every single nutrient they need,
including vitamin C.
So meat itself is definitely
not dangerous for us,
but its health effects vary depending
on how it's prepared and what animal it
comes from. When talking about
meat in the Western world,
we generally mean muscle tissues that
have a high nutrient density but also
lacks some of the vitamins that make
it possible to survive on meat alone.
The most healthy animals
to eat are probably fish.
Fish contains polyunsaturated fatty
acids like Amiga three which may low the
risk of cardiovascular diseases and
support anti inflammatory immune functions
as part of a balanced diet. Fish can
be eaten regularly without worries.
Eating fish comes with its own bag of
complications though like over fishing and
the destruction of the oceans. We'll
talk about that in another video.
A close second is the
most popular meat chicken.
It's regarded as the meat
with the fewest health risks.
The only negative health effect of
poultry is a bit controversial fat.
It's high content of saturated fats is
associated with a higher cholesterol
level and cardiovascular disease,
but this idea has also been criticized
by a large number of scientists arguing
high cholesterol levels might be
inherited and not caused by nutrition.
So in general, if you want meat and
are concerned about your health,
go for chicken.
Things start to get problematic with
high intakes of red meat like beef, veal,
pork, lamb, horse and goat.
A recently published study
recommends, for example,
a maximum of 23 grams of red meat per day,
which is a very small
steak per week. However,
large scale Meta analysis studies have
shown that eating 100 grams of red meat
every day increases the risk of
diabetes by 19% of strokes by 11% and of
colorectal cancer by 17%
this sounds alarming,
but before we panic,
let's have a look at how these studies
were conducted because this brings us to
the second big problem when trying to
answer the question of whether meat is
unhealthy or not.
Most studies that linked health risks
to eating red meat look case control
studies,
which means taking a group of people with
the disease and classify them by their
eating habits. The more
red meat they consume,
the more likely they were to
contract certain diseases.
The problem is that it's very
hard to eliminate other factors.
People who eat less meat tend to live
a healthier lifestyle. In general,
they tend to eat more vegetables and
fruit and are less likely to smoke and
drink alcohol. Most studies
try to eliminate these factors,
but it's extremely hard to
make definitive statements.
The things get worse.
When we look at processed meat though
processing meat means adding certain
chemicals by curing, smoking, salting
or fermenting or in other words,
making a delicious Bacon, Ham, Salami,
sausages and hotdogs contain chemicals
that are harmful for us like nitrates and
nitrites that can damage the DNA in our
digestive system and lead to cancer.
The WHO reviewed 800 studies over 20 years
and concluded that processed wheat is
strongly linked to an increased
risk of colorectal cancer.
Each extra 50 grams of processed meat
per day increases your risk of cancer by
18% when it comes to cancer risk.
Processed meat is now in the
same category as plutonium,
asbestos and smoking.
The who highlights that its research is
only about the question of whether or
not something causes cancer and not to
what extent that processed me to may also
significantly increased the chance
of suffering from diabetes, strokes,
and coronary heart diseases.
It also makes a difference what sort of
life army lived when it was still part
of a living being.
It's common to feed large amounts of
antibiotics to livestock in order to
prevent diseases which can
spread antibiotic resistance.
Combined a high consumption of both red
and processed meat could increase your
chance of premature death by up to 29%
this means if your chance of dying is at
3% this year, it's now 4% this
might not sound like a lot,
but tiny percentages have a huge
impact on societies of millions.
They also seem harmless
until they affects you.
To blame me to lone for bad
health would be wrong though.
There is no evidence that the very
essence of needs has any negative effects
beyond bids, high fat content, and
even this point is highly contentious.
Just like with many
other pleasures in life,
sometimes too much of a
good thing is harmful.
Most public health agencies suggest
cutting meat consumption to 500 grams a
week. While studies suggest cutting
down processed meat as much as possible,
so if you feast on meat no more than
once or twice a week, you should be good.
For most people, this already means
a drastic change in their diets,
though the average American consumes
around almost 1,600 grams of meat a week.
The average German 1,100 grams a week,
and many of us eat much, much
more. If you're not really sure,
make a small note. Whenever
you eat meat for a week or two,
you'll be surprised how much it really is.
So most people watching this video
would benefit from cutting down on meat.
Aside from health concerns,
they're still the fact that
the meat industry is one
of the largest contributors
to climate change and has reached a
scale where it's impossible to deliver
millions of tons of meat and
still treat animals with dignity.
We've already discussed that in
detail in another video. All in all,
in moderation.
Meat is not unhealthy and you don't need
to become vegetarian overnight to have
a real impact on your
health and the planet,
but your lifestyle choices do
matter for yourself and for others.
The key is being open to trying
something new. Once in awhile,
maybe you'll discover your new
favorite dish until you try.
You'll never know what you'll
enjoy or what you're capable of.
Maybe after watching hours of coats,
cars aren't videos you've decided you'd
like to learn how to animate. Now,
you might not know this,
but most of our team actually
has a graphic design background.
Learning about design principles first
before we got into animation was really
key to where we are today.
There's a really great new skill share
class on using Adobe illustrator.
The software we use to create
art work by graphic designer.
Aaron Draplin and we can
personally recommend it.
It's full of great tips to help
understand and simplify a very complicated
program if you want to do more afterwards.
We have three animation courses of our
own on skillshare to skillshare offers
over 25,000 classes on topics like
film and video editing, writing,
design and technology from
an array of skilled experts.
With the premium membership, you can
access all of them for only $10 a month.
And as a bonus,
the first 1000 coats cause aren't viewers
to use the link in the description
will get their first two
months of skill share for free.
[inaudible].